hello and welcome everyone this is
active inference guest stream 28.1 it's
October 14 2022.
today we are going to be hearing and
discussing reconceiving rationality by
Giovanni Rolla so Giovanni thank you so
much for joining very much looking
forward to this presentation and
discussion so off to you thank you
thank you then it was a pleasure to to
receive your invitation a couple of
months ago and I am delighted to be here
to have this opportunity to discuss my
work
um I'll spare your request
um our suggestion I am uh presenting
this paper I wrote a couple of years ago
and uh as we were talking the backstage
I have I I've changed my mind a few
times and I'm going to make this clear
during the presentation since I
published that paper but it is a
pleasure nonetheless to have the chance
to present this video here and uh to
share it with the world so I'm very
happy
uh so we'll be talking about
reconceiving rationality and this is the
this is the the
itinerary I was thinking about
presenting to you so first I'll be
talking about rationality and
contentless cognition then I'll present
my view which I called radically
inactive rationality and safety words
about agency and proficient interaction
and reasoning and rationality they are
close with a couple of objections the
first one being that
whatever I'm present in here is a true
liberal in a way excessively liberal it
encompasses too much and the second
objection which I think is the one that
may interest to you the most is whether
it is effect compatible with predictive
process in our predictive coding which
is of course in the facility in the it's
near the the two of cars in central to
do to active influence
so
here's the
here's the sorry
the my initial thoughts on the matter is
that traditionally the very
uh Orthodox have view on rationality
uh assumes to the most of my knowledge
it's as an assumption really that
rationality must in their reasoning
that for instance I believe B in an
action a are rational if and only if
there is the reasoning that underwrites
the Bure so and of course it's just not
any reasoning the reasoning question
must acquired with certain certain
formal benchmarks such as uh classical
logic or probability reasoning or
heuristics so believing and acting
rationally according to this traditional
film
require meeting certain formal standards
and this as I said it seems to me to be
largely an assumption about what it
means to be rational about defining
rationality in terms of reasoning
so if rationality requires reasoning
and if reasoning involves the evaluation
of beliefs against certain formal
benchmarks then rationality implies
content for cognition
where content I take it to be minimally
having accuracy conditions being capable
of being
right or wrong or in or in on a more
weightier notion being true or false so
the idea here is that rationality
necessarily involves content it involves
beliefs reasoning and the comparison or
sorry
to update right now
one software update I'm sorry there was
a a pop-up in my window over here so
um
that would be I think the the standard
view on rationality
and
if it is so that rationality necessarily
involves content it it is a good fit
with classical cognitivism or
cognitivism in general
which is the view that combination
necessarily involves representational
content at the very least for some
cognitivist of course it might involve
also
um
a conceptual content but at the very
least representational content which has
accuracy conditions
but this classical view is not so good
it does not provide a so good fit with
radically inactive and embodied
cognition
which I am here uh thinking not
specifically on radical and activism by
Goodwin Maine in the recent books but I
think it also challenges other views
that are not presented as radically and
active but of course they share some
core tenants with radical and activism
we could call them uh radically embodied
views of cognitions such as
um with the views presented by Ezekiel
Powell or Berman
sensory model life you also have
Gallagher's variety of inactivism in his
2017 book and also the I mean the view
by by Tony kimero in his 2009 book on
ecological psychology and dynamical
systems they all share common tenants
and here I am I know this is very
controversial but I'm treating those
views as radically embodied views of
cognition and but I'm specifically
focused on radical and active views of
cookination
they all say that not the recognition is
representational contentful which is in
a way to say that we can think of basic
contentless forms of cognition
or a contentless level basic level of
recognition
which emerges through the active
exploration of one's environment and
Beyond radical and activism by what we
mean
this could be this idea could be cashed
out in terms of mastering sensory motor
engagements a matter of know-how
the knowing how to engage with your
surroundings instead of knowing that
stuff are so and so around you so this
is very clearly what the Paulo and
colleagues and uh kimero for instance do
in their books uh radical and activism
has a certain tendency to skew sensory
model engagements sensory model schemes
Etc
and uh
but recent developments have I think
Incorporated that so the the this is the
use of the the gist of this idea right
so if we combine radical embodied views
of rumination or radical and activism
and the classical fuel on rationality
what we have is something that angle has
described as follows
an activism is the view that cognition
is grounded in a prayer rational
understanding of the world that is based
on sensory motor acquisition of real
life situation
and he explains these uh this idea of
pre-rational understanding
by
um
by by the the ideas of melopentin
Heidegger according to whom the relation
to the world can be only one rooting in
practice inactives in acting and
practicing intern is mediated through
the body so what seems to be implicit
here is that unlike acting and practice
rationality is not actually
it is something that is not at a very
basic level of combination so this is
what happened when we we
make room for a basic level of cognition
rooted in active and in practice and
divorce it from upper levels of
combination that they are usually the
locus the lucky classic of rationality
so
the idea in summation is that
contentious cognition or basic cognition
that which emerges through sensory motor
engagements is not rational
so sensory modern engagements however
virtues in prolific they can be cannot
be evaluated from the standpoint of
rationality only content for cognition
high level combination can be rational
definition that it is expressed for
instance in beliefs and recently
and well this is something that I
haven't touched upon on the paper but it
was my implicit motivation to deal with
this subject
as someone that comes from philosophy of
the mind is the idea of the myth of the
given at least a version of it
it seemed to me at the time and uh I was
correctly persuaded by a reviewer not to
touch on the subject it was very
convoluted in my initial presentation
but it seems to me that if we divide
base recognition from a rational thought
and action and we do not Point towards
the
well there is no I mean intersection
between these two levels it seems that
radical and activism and uh similar
views would be committed to the myth of
the given unpopularized by Sellers and
moderations by McDowell as a problem for
imperious fields of my mind
so it seems that this is I think a
[Music]
a philosophically interesting problem
but it's not something that is uh on the
Forefront of the paper it was my
implicit motivation here that to explain
how can we combine the contentless or
basic level of cognition through sensory
modern engagements with rationality if
you cannot it seems that uh there is a
given of some sort that is being uh
not completely explained in our picture
of the mind so this is something I
wanted to I still want to try to explore
this this intuition more clearly but I
haven't
touched upon this
um
but I I think there's something in the
direction of what why what I will show
today is I think it's a way to tweeze
this this accusation of being committed
to the myth of the given
so how can we reconceive rationality I
mean I think in order to avoid that
issue and avoid the idea that we have
two levels completely separated from
each other where one The Higher One is
the locus classical rationality and what
else is beneath it it's not rational I
think the idea is to rejected
rationality it must be defined or it
entails necessarily reasoning
does not need to be still conceived but
then the challenge becomes to offer a
positive
proposal of what rationality is if not
reasoning and here is Susan Hurley in a
paper that my knowledge is the only one
that it's
upon this subject and I think she was
also concerned about the myth of the
given by the way at the time and he is a
long quote from here phenomide me
reading it is that rationality might
emerge from a complex system of the
centralized hierarchy relations of
inhibition facilitation and coordination
among different horizontal layers Each
of which is dynamic and environmentally
situated rationality reconceived in
horizontal or modular terms uh I don't
know if she has to use this this
terminology but anyway that's how she
chose to express it is sustainably
related to the environment it does not
depend only on internal procedures that
mediate between input and output such as
content either for the organism as a
whole or for a vertically bounded
Central cognitive module rather it
depends on complex relationships between
dedicated World involving layers that
monitor and respond to specific aspects
of the natural and social environment
and of the neural network and reduce
their feedback from their responses this
to my knowledge is the earliest case of
someone working on the inactive approach
in a way
is obviously more
usually associated with the work of
avano which is also an activist but
in a different approach from radical and
activism and here is the the earliest
and to my knowledge before I wrote that
paper is that the clearest
uh proposal of rationality reconceived
in the native terms but it's not it's
not something that uh gained traction
after her publication to my knowledge
actually I haven't seen much since then
and to summarize the idea is that we
have to change the explanatory Focus
which is rationality is not exclusively
thought of as a Content involving
capacity in this proposal it is situated
or World involved in increased worlds
and is it is radically embodied it
depends on bodily morphology and action
and how the the organism is situated and
acts in that environment the idea will
be minimally dead so this is what I call
radically inactive rationality
is uh in a very
loose definition so far is that an Asian
acts rationally in so far as human
maintains a proficient interaction with
her environment coordinating her
cognitive abilities according to
environmental conditions of constraints
and solid stations and of course this
sometimes requires adapting to
unforeseen circumstances the the the
core intuition is this
and it's interesting to compare this
idea of radical and active rationality
with another of Susan Hurley's ideas in
a text from 2003 she's she says
reasons uh for acting that she argues
that reasons for acting may be context
bound where she's arguing against uh
Gareth Evans generality constraint
and this is the defense of the idea of
islands of practical rationality
so she is still treating rationality as
essentially something that relates to
reasoning here but this kind of
reasoning is bounded by practical
context so this is a very Progressive
view if compared with the traditional
view I I talked about at the beginning
but still more conservative than what I
am trying to develop here
so another thing that I think must be uh
in there the Forefront of this proposal
is that rationality implies agency and
autonomy because something or only
something that an organism does can be
said to be rational right
so to use these uh the ideas from the
autonomous and activist camp and from
the theory of how to players is
autonomous systems such as a Roomba
cannot be rational because it's not an
agent it is not the author of its own
behavior it is designed by external
agents to work in a certain way so it's
not strictly speaking a nation so that
is where I would draw the line of where
well you cannot it makes no sense to
ascribe rationality to a Roomba for
instance
and
for this I
I use the the Notions of autonomy and
adaptivity the DiPaolo and others you
have also the the recent book image the
four sensory model life and that famous
paper from the bowl from 2005 where he
talks about the adaptivity
to to set his very general constraints
on what it means to be Russian
so autonomous systems are thereby
conceived as precarious networks a
precarious network of processes because
organization and physical boundaries are
produced by the system itself the system
is continually maintaining its own uh
viability conditions which is
uh known as sense making where the
system explored uh environmental
environmental conditions that are
favorable to its uh self-maintenance and
avoids the ones that are detrimental to
it
so this is how I understand to be the
the very in general that they
emotional constraint on a rational being
that it must be an autonomous system
and the interesting thing here is that
the concept of adaptivity that Paulo but
forth is that the capacity of an
organism to improve its condition of
self-production through internal
structural changes
so it involves the monitoring and
regulation of internal changes in order
to select the best available course of
action it is I think it's another
interesting concept to think in of to to
including this idea of a radically
inactive notion of rationality one that
is not necessarily committed to
reasoning and content
so agency is realized through the
exercise of situated abilities that
promote changes within the organism in
accordance with environmental
constraints and substations
which means that how well an organism
adapts in order to deal proficiently
with its environment is a measure of or
an indication of its rationality the
more rational an organism is the more
suited it is to deal with its
environment and we have foreseen
circumstances
and in doing so the organism enhances
The Continuous exchanges between itself
and the environment
which is crucial for its survival and it
is very
naturalized way of thinking of
rationality is mostly capacity to to
enhance changes for survival
this is the
the overall idea here
so as I said before what about reasoning
I want to
I don't want to commit rationality
necessarily with reasoning and this is
what radically inactive rationality is
all about but I don't want to exclude
reasoning as a former rational
combination so what I'm saying is that
it's not defined by reasoning but it's
not uh it does not exclude reasoning
reasoning I think would be thought of as
a special or specific mode of rational
agency one that is exclusive to our
knowledge to human beings
but it's not the defining feature of
rationality
so for this I uh in order to to explain
this idea I recall how Hutu and Saturn
in between the paper in the most recent
book by utani they explain the emergence
of high recognition the idea is that
being able to engage in content for
cognition ultimately depends on being
social culturally embedded
where content full cognition emerged
from social cultural interaction so as
an individual takes part in Social
cultural practices
they accept more ancient cognitive
abilities to deal with symbols and by
doing so they
um in a long process of enculturation of
course
they become able to engage with uh
symbolic coordination which is not
internal representation specific because
it is publicly available it's not mental
representations in the traditional sense
but it has the features of symbolic
cognition without the the commitment to
internal representation or mental
representations
so acting rationally in its most General
sense is the idea that the proficient
behavior of an organism is in uh is is
the proficient behavior of an organism
in its environment it depends on the
coordination of embodied abilities
whereas reasoning if everything goes
well of course is understood as content
for rationality for my specific mode of
rationality reasoning is the proficient
behavior of an organism in a social
cultural environment
which is a more specific aspect of our
environment of course and it depends on
the coordination of such a culturally
based or content involving abilities
which are more recent in the the human
phylogenetic scale
so well this is the the biggest of the
idea this is the the I think
uh the the propositive part and here are
the objections I wanted to talk about
first one being that it's a very liberal
view it's very
uh it it is well it encompasses too much
one would say because if rational action
boils down to the coordination of
cognitive abilities then rationality is
something gradual for an organism could
be more or less proficient in its
environmental interactions
and the the rejection goes according to
radically inactive rationality many
organisms achieve and maintain an
Adaptive behavior in the niche with
different levels of success to which I
am uh well someone could sing rational
and active radical and active
rationalities to Liberal and this is one
objection that I I've heard in person
and I I kept it so hard because I think
it's very it's a very good way of
putting it evens nails are rational on
this View and that to which I must say
that I am willing to to buy the wallet
uh well yes it's more liberal than
traditional views of course it is
intended to be so but I don't think that
this per se problem what I think is the
the the positive part here is that it
preserves a difference of degree
humans are way more rational than other
animals simply because we are able to
perform a wide variety of actions in a
wide variety of dynamic circumstances
that are Way Beyond any other animals
that we are aware of
so to come back to the example of this
nail this nail can perform a few complex
actions can move from one point to
another it can search for food and
shelter and so on so forth but they have
a critical limited set of abilities if
you surround this nail with the South
for instance it is doomed to to die by
the retortation and humans on the other
hand they are much more adaptive and
able to deal dynamically with many
unforeseen circumstances so uh
in my response to that objection is that
yes
uh well it is very liberal but that's
not the problem the problem would be if
that it is if it had the room for a
difference of degree between how animals
deal with their environments
so and and this is the other object
objection which I think it may be though
the one that interests you the most then
you know is the 12 predictive processing
seems to imply inferences and content
all the way
uh but at first I must uh warn you and
the viewers that
at the time I wrote this uh this paper
was much more optimistic about this
possibility of combining an activism and
predictive coding or predictive
processing and uh I think there are
important points here but there is this
recent paper by Olu and Evan Thompson
and Randy beer where they uh they
provide a critical assessment of uh the
the the the attempts to combine mainly
the free energy principle and
um
inactive and
autobiographic theories so I am now
mostly convinced by the arguments but I
think there are some interesting points
of comparison here nonetheless
so predictive process in our predictive
code and uh at the time I was writing
and still to this day is all the rage in
the cognitive Sciences I guess you can
say that it sounded sweets become the
one of the main paradigms out there so
it is interesting to see if it provides
a good fit with what I'm talking about
and in these viewers you know
competition is understood as a process
of error minimization that occurs in
bidirectional narrow hierarchies
so
you have the generation of internal
models for the activity of lower layers
that anticipates the distal causes of
sinisterial stimuli which is a top-down
process and the minimization of
discrepancy between prediction and
current stimulus signal by
um the occupation of priors which is a
bottom of process
so here's of course active inference
which is understood by for instance in
an informal you know formal terms by
Clark that an organism moves its sensors
in ways that amount to actively seek in
our generation generating the sensory
consequences that they are rather their
brains expect
this is one way of understanding active
influencing very formal terms but I
think it gets the job done
so is the brain inferring the expected
source of received stimuli if it is
it seems that there is a there's an
issue with what I'm talking about
so the him voting reading of predictive
processing which is which uses the
product bias and inference right says
for instance that the process of
perceptionistas is separable from
rational broader biasing process of
prolification and context top-down
effects I felt that every intermediate
level of processing this has caught my
attention the way that Clark is also
talking about rationality all the way
but it's an inferential sort of
rationality
and pervasive influencer reasoning seems
to imply impervasive content
and then predictive processing seems to
be incompatible with radically inactive
rationality
well but there is uh at the time there
was and I think we can still argue in
several of the there's no
non-hemorrhoids and reading of
predictive processing
which uses for instance a one first step
would be to use a deflationary sense of
prediction that understanding cameo in a
short paper from 2013 but fourth where
the values of two or more variables
covari or are value reliably so the
value of 1 allows the Observer to infer
the value of another and here the
inference is happening happening at the
level of the observation not at one far
variable is inferring the value of
another so the idea would be I think
that content is in the eye of the
beholder the person who interprets how
the selection of censorial we put
approximates internal predictions here
understood in the inflationary sense can
describe it in inferential and biasing
terms so this is how I see for instance
the the idea about 4 000 by Bruno
paper which if I'm not mistaken
title is something like the brain is not
a scientist and the argument is in this
general direction
that we are projecting how
scientists construe brain activity as a
feature of the brain itself as if it
were predicting and inferring this more
uh robust or weightier sense
so what I'm trying to say here is that
active inference then I use double and
say double forgot the name of this in
English sorry
um it's not uh the literal sense of
inference here according to radically
inactive
uh rationality is that unarmed for the
efficiency of co-oriented behavior the
agent has to act in certain ways in
order for his his or her States come to
fruition more efficiently less costly
this does not imply the more contentious
claim that the generative models
themselves display and perform
predictive inferences this is a very
deflationary reading into predictive
processing to to provide this
combination with radical and active
rationality
and here's a kickoff in a paper from
by model it doesn't follow that an
organism has an internal
representational model of its niche in
that it is this model that those are the
cognitive work if you like instead an
organism is a model that is the causal
and statistical regularities reflect in
some environmental reflecting some
phenotype that is a model
and well
this relates to something that recently
uh my colleague notifica and I have been
talking about the idea of how organisms
bring forth a world according to an
activism which is idea that the organism
and environment are historically
historically called determined so
at the flow genetical scale this could
be explained through the idea of Niche
construction the idea that once an
organism is active in its environment it
promotes changes that if they are stable
enough they can be inherited by its
Offspring and these changes provide new
evolutionary press pressure pressures
that are that lead its evolutionary path
a similar idea has also been explored by
other description this time relating
Niche Construction
and the ecological psychology
so my my response to that objection is
that to act rationally means to achieve
a proficient engagement with the
environment through in a way prediction
and their minimization I'm willing to
accept that characterization but
rational and broader biasian processes
need not imply content for cognition if
we
if we understand that in the Flash no
sense prediction and their minimization
involve the selection of input and the
coordination of an interabilities in
World involvement manners which is well
exactly the main claim of radical and
active personality so I think to that
extent that predictive processing is not
uh an enemies would be rather than a lie
of this idea instead of uh
arrival but of course there are other
issues of compatibility that I have I
haven't touched upon here but that uh is
all I have thought of for today thank
you
awesome thank you very much
all right
cool very interesting
for those who are watching live please
feel free to write any questions I will
gather my notes and let's begin the
discussion
okay
well first just thanks again for the
talk
how about a little context on how you
came to be asking these questions in
your current position and how your
interests in this area developed because
there's so many interesting ideas and I
just wanted to learn more about how you
came to this Framing and sharpened your
point
okay thank you that's that's a good
question because it's not often that you
can explore this background
it matters so uh I was at the time I
think I was writing my PhD dissertation
it was maybe 2007 or something and uh I
was arguing for the idea that
rationality must be something that is
ultimately World involved in there is a
tendency to think of well even among as
I told as I showed you among uh in in
embodied periods with people of certain
it needs to be essentially World
involving such as acting and practice
and so forth
and perception of course but rationality
remains something like naturalizable
notion something that cannot be
brought down to the level of the the it
could not be scaled down in a way
like perception that could be explained
by a certain Dynamic engagement and so
on so forth
so at the time I was thinking that well
maybe this is
a knee issue because
on other
other contexts it is taken to imply that
whatever perception is if it is not
articulated in a way to provide a
certain fit with professional
combination then perception is a given
and this is the myth of the given
Dimension at the beginning and I thought
that well maybe this is something of
there is something of a myth of the
given working here on an active
cognition but this is not I think it's
not fatal because we couldn't principle
argue that instead of
uh construing the step perception and
other basic forms of combinations
involving Concepts and the like maybe we
could argue
from the other direction try to scale
down rationality in more not naturalized
level of
uh
so that was the motivation and it was
very it was a long review process and I
believe that my first the first version
of the paper the the viewer was very I
think they were correct entirely I I
endorsed the suggestion after all but he
was very uh
they were very adamant on taking that
part and I think it was for the better
because it it is another literature it
is another uh a lot of references that
are not usually in conversation with an
activism and body recognition and it was
very difficult just to put the matter in
the same terms to advance my arguments
so it's something that I scratched out
and I haven't thought too much about
that system but I think it's something I
would like to come back to and maybe uh
even probably someone has done so in the
in this last few years I'm not aware I
can remember but
this relation between an activism the
myth of the gift and it seemed to be it
seems to be very
obvious so it is I think something that
we could we should I mean uh be able to
explore but there's not something that
was in the the Forefront of the paper
but
but I had this idea to talk about
rationality in the flashing every sense
and at the same time I was reading a lot
about uh
called him from a philosophical
perspective of course I'm not as I said
very well versed in the technicalities
and the formalities of the the approach
but I was interested in the the
philosophical consequences there and I
thought well maybe there's something to
compare here because as Clark's
quotation show
you can talk about rationality all the
way and uh that's something I wanted to
to develop but not in a cognitivist view
but not radically embodied film so
that's the the the background
awesome thank you could you maybe
describe just what is the myth of the
given what was the context that that
myth arose in and where do we go after
bringing up the myth of the given
because I I saw it as a concept that you
wove in so what was it about
okay so the middle of the giving it that
well there are several possible Givens
depending on your flavor of philosophy
of mine but most classically in previous
fields of the Mind take the the the
content of perception to be given prayer
rationally in a way that we have certain
inputs that are uh just received by the
mind and the mind interprets it so
sellers different sellers is famous for
uh
having described his uh this problem as
a problem for not only increases fuels
of the mind but also for rationalists
but on the on the other side rational is
usually taken uh rational intuition as a
given which is to say that there is some
some level of cognition that is uh
unarticulate that it's given or as some
people talk about being bred given
but in a way there is this level of
cognition that is given and the mind has
to interpret it but if it is given in
this way it has no point of contact no
uh intersection between whatever
whatever mind does and and this basic
level of uh domination so my idea is to
avoid the the charge of being committed
to the myth of the given but again this
is not something that is explicit in the
the nativist literature but it's
something that seems to be possible to
to develop in a
I mean uh in this sort of comparison but
it's not it's not from the
not clearly there but
one way of solving them for the Givens
to say that perceptual content is
already conceptual in nature which is
for instance how Joe McDowell does in
mind the more of that you know a
perception uh the the joke is comes with
subtitles you and interpret the world as
as you do but uh
I think that one way or another way is
to demystify you know a rationality and
the upper layers of combination try and
try to think of them uh uh in less
uh content for analysis
without committing them so it's strictly
speaking with a level of content that is
divorced from basic levels of
combination that's one way I think of
doing so and rationality seems to be the
one key concept to do this because
it's all usually assumed to be something
exclusively human and something that is
related to reasoning and well if it is
so then rationality cannot inform action
and if of course if the action is
contentless in nature so if rationality
is a sense essentially contentful and
reaction is essentially uncontained for
contentless then you can you do not have
this
uh that's done this uh intersection
between two domains and this is
something I wanted to avoid but as I
told you it became so hard to express
this views in in
sufficiently clear and general way is
that by recommendation of our reviewer I
scratch that out and I
I still think about it but nothing I
haven't developed a proper
line of argumentation that deals with it
more clearly than I can do as I just did
in very general terms
cool well some words that you associated
with rationality were adaptivity
and also proficiency so what do you see
as the relationship of rationality and
Fitness
as a biological function right yes yeah
okay I um
I think it is it is an intrinsic
relation really I think it is
uh probably the most
[Music]
um
obvious consequence of rational action
at a special scale and when we talk
about whether rationality is a feature
of uh certain species or instead of
individuals I think Fitness is one of
the
the key Concepts here to to think this
as the the outcome of this
uh rational action
so although I do not say that I do not
put it in those matters in the paper I
think it is possible to think it that
way you know don't see it as a
as an objection to think think of
rationality but again it's very liberal
and I'm willing to to accept this
consequence as well every living
organism in a way if it if it hasn't
gone Instinct yet so it is in a way
fitted to its environment so I'm willing
to see that it may involve a minimal
level of rationality of dealing with uh
the enemy changing environment
but well and it's the price of having a
very
uh
liberal Progressive notion of
rationalities this is a consequence of
it I believe
so you've said that Fitness is is a
consequence of rational Behavior are
there other consequences or how do we
recognize rationality from the outside
other than just saying well the ant
colony is thriving so to the extent that
it is rational it is adaptive an
exhibiting agency and all of that
um is this such a deflationary
rationality concept that all extant
things humans and otherwise are merely
described by it or are there some
outcomes that we can use to disentangle
like for example a rational or
irrational behavior from merely the
consequences reflected by survival and
Fitness
right well I I had to to think very
carefully about this because I don't
want to trivialize this concept in a way
that well everything is IPS of fact or
rational by the matter of fact that it's
living it is acting relationship but I
think that uh in particular cases one
could uh identify the nation that I am
equal to the individuals
um self-sustainment in that Niche so so
at the individual level in particular
okay this is one conclusive certain
actions that could classifiers
irrational to the extent that they uh
are detrimental to to with survival but
uh at the species level it's more
difficult to argue in that way because
to identify this kind of behavior or
consequence but I think that in order
to not to trivialize the idea of
rational and say well everything that is
living is a factorized you'd have to to
identify this sort of particular acts
that are detrimented to
to one survival
so in the case of the the ant colony I
don't know maybe
welcoming invasers would be a
would be the sort of behavior that would
be prejudicial to with
survival as such
I don't know I don't know if this is uh
it's one impossible way of thinking
about this I had to think more clearly
but
my carefully
oh very interesting and you brought in
in that answer and in the presentation
like multiple
nested time scales just like Eco Evo
Devo does from a more biological
perspective looking at how Niche
construction Bridges the gap between
slower phylogenetic processes and more
rapid developmental processes
um so how does this
embedded and multi-scale consideration
relate to the the content
concept like is content going to be
localized in one body or is the content
distributed across entities or is the
rationality distributed across entities
how would we even identify the locus
of rationality and that also kind of
invokes the um horizontal and modular
conception from the quote that you
provided so how do we identify salient
spatial temporal scales and systems of
Interest
oh ah I don't know I don't know if I can
answer uh this fully but it seems to me
that at the level of uh if we're talking
about content for instance content as a
accuracy conditions for symbolic
thoughts I think fortunately we have to
say that it's it's not localized in a
single individual it's publicly shared
so you can say that
um
one consequence of this is that it's
possible to think of different uh
patterns of reasoning that have
being information
sites at different times Etc and you can
see that well they developed different
level different uh rules for Content
information
and I think this is
plausible to say that content is
is localized that the the
uh how can you say it's share the amount
you know the specifics of
just for rationality I think
one could
[Music]
identify in particular behaviors
if it if it fits these uh
this kind of description of uh spin
proficient proficient interaction and
adaptive interaction between an organism
and its environment its Niche so
probably we could
we could give different answers here as
a rationality and content I I am willing
to say that
content for organization is not
something that happens in the head
something that is out there in a way
share the amount of others and this is
something that the philosophy of mine
has at least since the 60s the
philosophers of mine have been argued
for the idea that content is externally
individuated
and uh I'm I think this is it is one of
the video by for instance Hillary Putnam
and Tyler Burge and others that the
mental content is individuated at the
community level or societal level but
along there on the other hand they think
rationality could be in principle
individuated in particular behaviors but
it would depend on the individual's
goals and the the niche it inhabits and
so on so forth
there are of course actual variables
here that might be important too
to identify
Behavior as rational or not
okay
thanks
um well one phrase that really stuck
with me was like know how not know that
perhaps uh a basal point in your work
and a focus on that action so I just
wanted to
hear about how action and practice as
you wove them here today how are those
terms addressed
and how are things different today with
the treatment of action and practice and
know-how not know that than say in the
helmholtzee in days or even in ancient
or in World Knowledge traditions
So Okay cool so the idea I think would
be that
um
there is a tendency from uh it is a
tendency from a very modern philosophy
but it has been very influential in the
first wave of cognitive science to think
of perception as
a capacity to categorize the environment
and to offer a discrete description of
environmental aspects so for instance
perceiving that uh the the the the
that I know the the cup is to my left is
a matter of knowing that there is a
thing with searches such properties to
my left and this is a kind of uh know
that a kind of propositional attitude
towards the world so
uh I think the the
interesting thing about an activism and
ecological psychology as well and to the
extent that they recall the American
pragmatism from the the beginning of the
century is to think of
perception as a matter of not
categorizing these great properties in
the world but as uh disclosing
possibilities for acting
and this is something that if we were to
explain that in terms of uh in epidemic
terms such as knowledge we wouldn't put
it as a matter of knowing that the the
curve is to my left but knowing how to
grab the cup and do whatever I want to
do with it if I want to drink a cup of
coffee or if I want to use it as a
paperweight it will have different
silent properties and this is something
that
although it has been I think
very I think an activism and ecological
psychology and other embodied views of
cognition have been largely successfully
in shifting this discussion to this
point I think in the uh in more
traditional cognitive Sciences you still
have the idea that well
organism organisms perceived by by
describing the way the environment
this is something that I think
uh more traditional readings of
predictive processing make uh be clear
as in uh the idea that you're inferring
about the the source of stimuli and not
in uh and not and this is not I mean
this is more easily amenable to the idea
that the the brain or the cognitive
system knows that
the the world is so and so
the environment is so and so instead of
saying that the agenda system knows how
to engage with the world and I believe
the
the the point that
an activists and uh ecological
psychologists are trying to make is to
and also working on the the predictive
coding and the free energy principle
Etc is to show that these Notions these
Frameworks could be a minimal idea that
the kubernetes system is knowing how to
engage it knows how to engage in
environment in a way it doesn't need to
be read inboard summary
that the the Kindle system is inferring
that the world is so so I think this is
one way of explaining but also uh
philosophically if you have a large at
the beginning of the the last few
decades uh a gigantic discussion about
whether no Cloud could be reduced to
know that and then again you have a
background of this and other
as an independent notion from you know
that and whether you could
reduce one to the other and so forth so
I think it doesn't stop there you cannot
uh even though I can make a a claim for
perceptional some other knowing how
they're still the the background issue
of whether know-how could be treated as
and all that
anyway this is something that I am also
working on recently
there's a lot to say there it's it's
such an interesting idea especially with
linguistic communication it's a little
bit like the finger and the moon and
talking about the moon but the finger is
only where it is and we're not talking
about the pointer we're talking about
the reference
and so to use
a sociocognitive form of communication
in in cultured language
or in written academic discourse to peer
through that or to reimagine that and
see even what seems to be like the
Pinnacle of know that
and still see it as know how
I guess the question there is
how do we read papers
yes of course yes I think it is uh it is
a
uh it's yeah the values it seems to be
able to be a very big problem because if
we try to to treat these negative
capacities as you mentioned as a matter
of know-how
it seems that we still miss something
about communication for instance and on
the other hand I think and this is my
intuition but I think that we could in
principle talk about
how
understanding what you just said and
trying to respond to it is a matter of
knowing how to behave linguistically
but I think that even this movement
to treat high levels of cognitionists
which made it a matter of know-how it
still leaves something out
I am at I mean personally I am
and pleased with it I think at some
level we've got to say that well that is
another kind of approach that is needed
here to explain how we communicate for
instance in
very adequate not to say that it does
not involve and now but it's not just
that I think that at least more than
practical knowledge is needed
but maybe the key here is to think of
practical knowledge just basic and
necessary for other sorts of other other
kinds of knowledge that they are needed
to engage in this sort of Exchange
maybe maybe the maybe this is one layer
I'm sure that
well
uh more has to be
said about this to given a more
informative answer but this is a at
least my current position is that
no how provides the basis of our
engagement with the world and with
others but at some juncture we have to
to be able to develop other kinds of
understanding to explain a very explain
the complex sorts of uh exchanges we
have in our daily lives
such as reading papers as you said
I I agree I think
framing know that as the basis and then
recovering know how is a challenge and
it's also a challenge to begin with the
basal cognitive processes as being
enacted no house and to reassemble those
know-how pieces into know that again
it's not necessarily even a simple
challenge but would we rather confront
the challenge of assembling symbolic
propositional declarative verbal
Etc cognitive processes from a more
liminal
ecological cognitive approach
or try to recover the ecological from
the turing machine in a sense so it
seems like
um
you're speaking in support of grounding
in ecological plausible basal cognitive
processes and then working towards
assembling the skyscraper
yes yes yeah totally yeah I think it's
well
both uh
those both approaches are difficult to
to
to assemble as you said to to to provide
this uh sort of explanation either
bottom left or top down but I am more
favorable of course to the the web
approach I think it also for another
reason it it seems to the point of
departure seems to be
a biological description of how we
interact with the world and the other
way around it seems to be much more
difficult to explain uh how we come up
with this uh biological questions such
as our body morphology and such it seems
that we have to first account for that
and then you we get to the the other
questions which are also hard to to
answer but at the very least I I think
it's a
the bottom up approach is more uh
integrative in a way is that the chances
are it seems to be more
uh in our favor in the sense
and and the way you just kind of framed
it made me think that if you were to
program a computer from scratch
it could be an abstract or a virtual
computer so it doesn't even need to have
a specific embodiment
and in that situation one might be
concerned with assembling
know that assert that and assembling
these declarative
statements and logic processes into
something that is more dynamical or in
interacting with the environment however
that process of like full stack
engineering
with logic and silicone at the base
is quite different from how we got here
and so it might but it's it's
complimentary
um well you gave a little visibility
into uh I guess the before during and
after of peer review so I was just
curious what
changed during and after the paper like
over the last months or years or however
long it was how did you evolve on this
and then what do you see as relevant
next steps whether they're for you or
just general to be done are we looking
for a brain measurement are we looking
for a video camera in a forest are we
looking for a conceptual Advance what is
going to move forward past your
developments
that's that's a great question I think
um
I I'm not completely satisfied with the
way I I'll use foreign level I don't
know if this any of these would be
carried out in uh I honestly don't know
if you could in principal carried out in
other empirical terms but
uh I'm not saying that uh well
one is I would write it a bit
differently today not that it's uh not
that I disagree with the paper
originally but I think I
there's something some points that I
would like to reframe but they do not
authorize uh either I think he had a new
paper
but maybe in the future but this is
something that
the questions such as the myth have
given which is still the philosophical
question
and conceptual one they still uh bother
me but I have yet to
to find the opportunity to develop these
ideas more carefully and the the general
view I put forth there I think I I think
it still stands
uh but
um
I would like I I still I'm waiting for
this chance to elaborate it further and
see how far I can get but I don't know
yet I must admit I don't know what are
the the future developments of this idea
but um I've been working on several
isolated
issues on this approach
for the last few years I've worked with
the notion of information and scientific
understanding and information for
ecological and an activists of
combination and recently I am working
more recently with a few colleges on
virtual reality and perception
recognition so uh
this is how I like to to conduct my
research to find interesting
uh questions and see how how can I deal
with them but not necessarily find
myself
uh tied to one
one line of reasoning that way so this
is what happened at the time I was
working with rationality if I thought it
was a very cool subject and uh I still
think it is but I haven't had the time
to come back and reframe what I wanted
to but uh maybe maybe sometime in the
near future I don't know but more the
most recent thing I've been working on
does not involved in cellular
rationality but I think some products
could be wrong which is that of a
virtual reality and
how does uh visual reality actually
compares to combination because
well there's obviously something missing
from a perseverance and a visual
environment right
um there is of course if I someone for
instance if if I'm on a visual
environment where I am under a kind of
threat I may feel something analogous to
fear but I'm not really fearing for my
life
and imagine that the person on the
virtual reality so is it rational to to
run away from
the the threat the virtual threat and so
on so forth this is this the the this is
what I'm working on and uh maybe it's it
provides a point of return to this
the idea of radical and active
rationality and in fact uh the paper
just got accepted so as I was telling
you before I was so busy these last few
days because we were correcting proofs
my colleagues and I never figurative
uh and I I was
with a tight schedule too
to submit the corrected version of the
paper in the last few weeks and then I
got the proofs and
oh
uh well maybe uh in the future I can
come back to the issue of rationality
I'd like to but I don't know if I I
don't know I I really can't foresee the
developments of that but uh in general I
still agree with my original idea but
I'll frame it differently a little bit
so the VR point I'm sure that there's a
lot more to say there but it reminded me
of just the title virtual reality it's a
virtualization and so in the same way
that
cognitive action planning
allows us to entertain
policies that our body doesn't take
if only to evaluate them and choose
against them but we can go on a flight
of fancy have a Whimsical policy
selection process
of counterfactuals
mentally
but then our morphology is kind of like
our Lifeline you know if you actually
fall off a ledge then it's going to hurt
and then in virtual reality
you're embodied
perceptual experience is quite literally
a virtualization of
survival critical situations so you
might see yourself as being on a ledge
but you're on a flat floor
and then in that situation
if you're kind of
um a cognitive Observer outside of the
video game you might say well it's
rational for me just to fall off to see
what happens
so that's like but then there's a layer
of rationality within the space yes like
what's a good move in the game
um and so it's kind of blurring the line
between
[Music]
it's it's blurring the criticality of
the body and um
I'm sure you've thought about this much
more so how does this play into our
virtual reality
um with the ways we think about and use
and design these systems
well this is the the the the the the
questions that motivated us to write a
paper and uh NADA give them and I was
that in the technical literature you see
that a lot of researchers working with
the uh treat uh visual perception as
illustri a kind of Illusion but we were
a bit bothered by that because on the
other hand it only works in VR because
we we embodied the devices devices they
work for us you have the controllers you
have the the headset
and uh it seems so weird to say that the
user the the user is under a kind of
Illusion
and on the other hand it seems that it's
not actually cognition because as you
said there is no there is no biological
uh relevance to those uh cognitive
States so to speak for instance if I see
an apple in VR it's it does not afford
nourishing but it makes sense within the
game right but the different uh well
well I've received an apple in a in an
actual environment it is it affords
nourishment it is something I can eat
but not in VR I can pretend to so we
coined this uh concept of allusion to
its plane
uh it is as if we were
facing an actual animal but it involves
also this volition of play this idea
that we are not
being misled because we put on the
equipment we know we are in the game and
this I think is a hot subject right now
because there's metaphors and I am very
skeptical of whatever
that can people are very optimistic but
about the possibilities of the metaverse
and some authors really think that we
could be in a simulation in this
strictly speaking but I mean the best
technology the current technology shows
us is that it's very limited and you can
pretend to be in a certain environment
and so forth and this I think may offer
a new new ways of thinking of
thinking about rationality in this
visual environment in ways that maybe
Russians do something that environment
has said to jump off the ledge and see
what happens and on the other hand
behavioral aspects of doing so sometimes
people actually feel fear and people
face the street for phobias with virtual
realities
and
um it's it's a lot of there's a lot of
interesting questions there that
maybe I mean for future research we can
yeah back to it it made me think about
how the Apple in real life it could be
calories for you but also it could be
calories for a fly it could be thrown
you could use it as a hammer you could
paint it right so
ecology and the generative process as
we'd say an active inference kind of
is always going Beyond
whatever affordances were programmed in
for a given object and then also
um the current discourse on VR focuses
heavily on headsets
just speaking totally anecdotally not
not my expert area
um it seems a little bit interesting
it's like as if the mobile phone
discussion was only focused on
rectangles of a certain size
what makes this not virtual reality it's
like looking through a window and
there's another fellow to speak with so
it's not attached to my head it doesn't
have some of the motion tracking
um capacities that some technologies
have but it is
a niche modification in Perry personal
space
and we can push
signals and affordances to each other
so having a VR framing or really just a
framing of rationality and perception
cognition action Cycles
that
aren't just constrained to one specific
realization or Hardware type and can run
the gamut from Total offline
person in a field
to somebody who's very
in The Matrix
seems pretty relevant otherwise new
technologies even little variants and
software updates will continue to just
infinitely surprise and confuse
yeah I think it's a it's a it's hard to
define the the boundaries
I mean we are here uh in an exchange
which I think it could increase but be
classified as a form of virtual reality
of course I'm seeing you ruin your C
mind but
uh I mean most I think works out they
nowadays they they find it a doc by
saying that well must have a headset and
sometimes a controller but but other
than that sounds virtual reality but
yeah it's hard to Define anything uh
it's not it's not a dump and
straightforward that's one of the things
because on uh talking commercially of
course virtual reality means headsets
and and other paraphernalia but but a
phone just talking on the phone or a
telegraph in that time it would have
been on that interface with that sensory
modality and with those affordances it
is the virtualization
yeah that we have access to of just a
different chapter today
yeah I think so yes part of our paper
was to argue that in a way embodying
technological devices is obviously in
the need not that's not new it is the
mark of Being Human
it's embodying technological devices
what made us what we are since the
beginning using analytic technology and
the fact that we can embody it so
proficiently a device even if it is
programmed to for instance uh in within
virtual reality to have something a
creature you control us richer with new
morphology another morphology for
instance even if that's the case it only
happens so proficiently because we are
able to embody the device some
experiments have shown that you can map
for instance a Twist of your wrist to a
third arm
uh that individual reality goes from was
that from your chest and people can
learn to control this third arm that
doesn't map into our actual morphology
but it can be made so by a Twist of the
wrist so
this is something we will discussed in
our paper that well you can
you can only do that because you embody
the device you can see it's an illusion
it's actually well
part of what me is being human is to
embroidery technological devices so
I would go that way I mean I know it
blurs the distinction between virtual
and non-virtual buds I think that's one
way of dealing with this
cool is there anything else you want to
talk about ask or just kind of Prelude
ah well I I'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to discuss this paper it was
very nice for me I I really enjoyed it
and this is uh very nice and uh
comfortable environment to discuss these
issues and think thank you once again
thank you yeah awesome discussion and
important topics and we'll be happy to
talk to you again anytime
okay thank you farewell thank you